[موسيقى]
تتوقع موجه اكتساح الحمراء في الانتخابات
النصفيه
الان يجد نفسه يتعامل مع العديد من الظروف
التي هي نتائج اداره
وقود مرتفعه جدا وتذكر ان الناس هنا
يحتاجون لقياده سيارتهم من اجل الوصول
لمقارات اعمالهم ولذلك فان الامريكي اصبح
يتساءل عما اذا كان يتعين عليه الدفع من
اجل الوصول الى مقر عمله او الدفع من اجل
اطعام اطفاله هذا قرار صعب ومهم وخطير
ويومي امام المستهلك الامريكي هذا فضلا عن
مستويات التضخم وارتفاع نسبه الجريمه في
البلاد
[موسيقى]
في جميع هذه الميادين سياسه الجمهوريين هي
الافضل بل انها نقاط قوتهم وهناك قناعه
لدى الكثيرين الان بانه لو كانت هناك
اداره جمهوريه حاليا في البيت الابيض
وما كان لنا ان نبعد ابرز حلفاءنا
التقليديين المهمين وفي مقدمتهم المملكه
العربيه السعوديه وانا مقتنعه بمناسبه انه
عندما يستعيد الجمهوريين رئاسه البلاد عام
2024 ستستعيد العلاقات بين الرياض واشنطن
مستواها التاريخيه التقليدي وبسرعه
والناخبون الامريكيون العاديون تاكدوا
الان ان اخطاء الحزب الديمقراطي هي التي
طلبت معها حياتهم وان الجمهوريين هم
الاقدر وهم الممثلون اقرب لهم بفعاليه
سياساتهم الامنيه وما يتعلق بالتضخم
والطاقه وملفات التعليم وغيرها ولذلك نحن
متاكدونا من ان البلاد ستشهد اكتساحا
للجمهوريين في الانتخابات المقبله حيث
نرجح الفوز بالاغلبيه وذلك في انتظار فوزي
بالبيت الابيض علما ان الكثير من
الجمهوريين سيسيطرون على منصب الحاكم في
عده ولايات
[موسيقى]